Luna Lovegood is an absolute treasure
and we'd go as far as saying that Harry
couldn't have defeated Voldemort without
her from fighting for justice and
Dumbledore's Army to helping Harry find
the last Horcrux Luna has proven herself
to be a lot more than loony she is loyal
creative intelligent and an all-around
amazing friend but she's also a hero
Harry Potter
without Luna wouldn't really be Harry
Potter at all and here's why after
Cedric lost his life to Voldemort at the
end of the Triwizard Tournament Harry
was still reeling from not only seeing
what happened but also knowing that
Voldemort was really back no one
believed him he was grieving for a
friend and he had witness to something
traumatic enter Luna Lovegood we realize
how important Luna is right away in
order of the Phoenix because she's the
only one who was able to see thestrals
along with Harry
despite Lunas cheerful attitude she lost
her mother very young and she saw it all
happened she describes her mother as an
extraordinary witch who lost her life to
a spell gone wrong Harry can't
immediately find some comfort in Luna
she's there to promise Harry he's not
crazy and that it's okay to have strong
emotions she tells him some might hate
these words coming from Luna Lovegood
but Harry sees them as hopeful if Luna
can witness something traumatic and come
out of it strong kind and happy then why
can't Harry
the thing about Luna is that she never
looks for validation from others but
she's there to give Harry validation for
his feelings when he needs it most
Harry shows us how important Luna is to
him by granting her own wish to
interview him for the Quibbler after
spending so much time avoiding rita
skeeter here he gives his words about
baltimore to the one person who he
thinks will listen and not twist his
words and it's this interview that helps
people realize that Voldemort really is
back Luna proves that sometimes the pen
really is stronger than the sword this
means the most Harry who really just
needs someone to listen to him without
judgement the trust Harry gives Luna is
given back to Harry tenfold after a few
months of knowing Harry and his friends
Luna is willing to set off with them to
save Sirius black from the Ministry
there
she witnesses another hugely traumatic
moment in Harry's life the loss of
serious and while Luna may not have been
able to stop this from happening she
does share her particular brand of Luna
wisdom with Harry
she says it's easy to look at Luna
strange hats and spectacles in the
Quibbler she carries around everywhere
and think okay this girl yeah she's lost
her marbles but Luna was there for
Harry's mental health when he needed it
most without her support would Harry
have ever been able to deal with his
grief Luna could have easily been an
emotional support character but instead
she also became a secret weapon it's no
coincidence that after Voldemort comes
back the series starts to get darker and
darker Luna is one piece of the puzzle
that continues to bring light and
hopefulness to the story you can look to
her for strange stories about NIF lers
and eccentric fashion choices sure but
she's also ready in a pinch to help save
the world Lunas Patronus is a hair which
symbolizes intelligence creativity
swiftness and thinking outside of the
box
it makes her the perfect addition to
Dumbledore's Army in the half-blood
Prince she's one of the few students who
fights the Death Eaters in the Deathly
Hallows she helps the army find a way
for Harry to sneak back into the school
and in the Battle of Hogwarts she's
fighting on the front lines Luna never
backs down but perhaps her biggest show
of bravery happens in the Deathly
Hallows after she gets kidnapped and
ends up in Bellatrix's basement she
spends months there but when Harry and
Ron show up she's smilin and even after
this traumatic experience
Luna still returns to Hogwarts where she
tries to steal the Sword of Gryffindor
from Snape's office all of Lunas bravery
comes down to the one moment where she
saved the entire wizarding world by
using nothing but kindness and
intelligence
Harry would never have been able to
locate Ravenclaw's lost diadem without
her it's her bond with the Grey Lady
that convinces the ghost to tell Harry
where it might be
in the castle and it's Luna who solves
the riddle that gets them to it without
her the Horcrux might never have been
found so what can we learn from Luna a
character who is so well remembered for
being weird and quirky but who also
played an irreplaceable role in
defeating Baltimore let's start with
what she teaches us about fitting the
status quo we know she's incredibly
smart and ingenuitive because she's in
ravenclaw but Luna proves that not every
member of each house has to fit the same
mold her creativity wits and drive to
learn without being like everyone else
is what makes her a ravenclaw but she
embodies so much self-acceptance bravery
and kindness that she could easily fit
into Gryffindor Hufflepuff Luna also
teaches us to look past appearances her
head is in the clouds but she's also one
of the most intuitive people in the
series in the books she sees right
through Harry's Weasley disguise that
bill and Phil's wedding for example she
sees people for who they really are and
she doesn't let looks fool her this is
one of her strongest character traits
because despite members of her own house
bullying her she still finds a way to be
open and love others and herself so
where does Luna end up while she married
newts commander's grandson Rolfe and
they had twins named Lauren and Lysander
and after the bottle of Hogwarts her
former cellmate Ollivander even gives
her one of the rarest gifts of witch or
wizard can be given a custom-made wand
Harry also gives Luna a gift he names
his daughter Lily Luna Potter after her
so Luna a girl who spent so much of her
life being the outcast found herself
surrounded by friends and even honoured
by them Luna teaches us all that if we
stay true to ourselves our strengths
will find a way to shine so Thank You
Luna for teaching all us weirdos that
it's okay to be exactly who we're meant
to be do you agree that the Wizarding
World wouldn't have been the same
without Luna Lovegood let us know why
you love Luna in the comments section
below don't forget to hit that like
button if you enjoyed this video and
subscribe to the things for more thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time